Today we're speaking with
Liz Shuler, the secretary
treasurer of AFL-CIO.
Liz is not only the
chief financial officer
for the AFL-CIO, she
has a special interest
and responsibility in
working with young people
to introduce the
Labor Movement to them
and to learn from
them about what
they would like to see the Labor
Movement of the future look
like.
So I'm the secretary
treasurer, which
is the chief financial
of the AFL-CIO.
We have 57 affiliated unions.
And I actually
came up through one
of those unions,
the International
Brotherhood of
Electrical Workers,
as a rank and file member.
And my responsibilities
here are to manage the money
and make sure that we're
using the dues money wisely
and building
program, making sure
that our finances are in order.
But in addition to
that finance hat,
I also work to engage,
educate, mobilize young people
in our movement, particularly
focused, as a woman officer,
in making sure that we are
engaging women in our Labor
Movement and really speaking
out on issues that affect women
in the workplace, and then
in terms of innovation,
what can we be doing
as a labor movement
to change as the workplace
changes and evolves?
And that can include anything
from workforce development
and training to issues
around the on-demand economy.
There's so much happening
in the world of work.
Well, the young people
in the Labor Movement--
I was a young person when
I first started in my union
at 23 years old--
often feel that they
don't have as much
of a voice in our
Labor Movement.
And I wanted to figure out a
way to change that and make
their ideas and opinions and
thoughts and approaches woven
into the fabric of
what we do every day.
So we started a young worker
program we call NextUP
about six years ago.
And the intent was
to figure out ways
to get young people engaged
in their own unions,
but also making connections with
young people outside the Labor
Movement so that we're
all working together
to advance the interests of
young people in this economy.
And we've been building
young worker groups
all across the country
through our AFL-CIO structure.
So in most major cities and
pretty much every state,
we have a young
worker group that's
giving voice to young people.
They're leading in
politics, in legislation,
in organizing, and
really being a voice
and a presence for
the Labor Movement
in their local communities.
I'm really proud
of the work they've
done to put together a young
worker economic platform
so that they can
hold politicians
accountable on the issues
that matter to young people
in the economy.
And of course, front and
center is job opportunities,
making sure that when people
graduate from high school
or even graduate from
college that we have
good jobs waiting for them.
And often, we know young
people are grappling
with a lot of student
loan debt when they've
gone through college
and how are our elected
officials responding to that
and really connecting the Labor
Movement to the issues that
matter to young people?
Well, the course is a real
opportunity for young people
to connect on what is the future
of work going to look like?
What are we doing as working
people to influence that?
And in the labor movement,
of course, front and center
is collective bargaining
and how can we
strengthen collective
bargaining and how
does the role of collective
bargaining influence
work in general?
We know the unionized
workforce has been shrinking,
but in a time of the greatest
inequality we've seen,
it's more important than ever
that we grow the Labor Movement
and get our fair share of
that growth in the economy.
And so I think for
young people who
are looking at what can I
do to influence, what can I
do to help, taking a course
like this, educating themselves,
but then also taking
that education
and moving it into action.
And I think when I
talk to young people,
they often feel
powerless and don't
see the Labor
Movement as a vehicle
for that kind of action.
And so I think the
message is that yeah,
there are opportunities.
There are places you can
go to exert your power.
And the power of coming
together in the power
of collective action, nowhere
is that better on display
than with the Labor Movement.
Young people in
the Labor Movement
have a very unique perspective.
They often are some of the
only young people in their peer
group that have
a decent job that
pays benefits, that gives
them the training they
need without going into debt.
So I think that they can do a
service to other young people
who may not know those
opportunities exist
by lifting up the possibilities
of what the Labor Movement can
offer.
They also have a
unique perspective
on what's happening
in the economy.
As we know, this generation
has suffered disproportionately
with the lack of opportunity.
The unemployment numbers
have hit them, I think,
at double the rate of the
average who's out of work.
And we want to come together
as a society to figure out,
what kind of jobs do we
want to see in this country
as we go forward in the future?
Do we want low-road,
f jobs or do
we want opportunities to
really support your family
and put food on the table?
And I think young people are
feeling that so acutely and so
they have ideas and
thoughts to share
on how we can
rebuild the economy.
So I think that this
is a great opportunity
to bring people together,
have their voices heard,
make sure that we're getting our
politicians' attention on this
because those
elected officials are
the ones that write the
rules and pass the policies.
And so if we're going to rewrite
the rules of the economy,
we need to get more
and more young voices
in that conversation.
I think there is
so much opportunity
at this moment in
time as, of course,
the workplace is
changing and evolving.
So is the Labor
Movement and so is
the progressive
infrastructure in the country.
And I think the message
is that we don't just
have to sit back and
wait for change to happen
and feel like we can't
be a part of that change.
I think it's important that
you see the Labor Movement
as a vehicle for that
possibility of bringing
people's voices together.
And as an institution,
we can do that.
But we can't do it alone.
We need to be working
together in collaboration
and in partnership with
all kinds of organizations.
And the more people we bring
together, the more powerful
our voices are.
So I think for young
people who are looking
for an avenue and a way to
make change, certainly look
to the Labor Movement, but
look in your communities.
Look at all the
different organizations
that are lifting up
voices in different ways.
Look at your local
businesses, for example.
We often think that
labor and management are
at odds with each
other, but could we
be more powerful if we
were working together
in collaboration on the
things that matter to creating
better jobs, high-road,
high-wage jobs?
And so I think that
young people will
play an integral and important
role in making that happen.